Okay
for the decree.
Okay.
Why does it,
why do you care about the degree?
To get a job.
Okay.
Whose decision was it that you
took the degree that you're taking?
Your S.
Okay.
Did your parents have
any influence on that?
No.
No?
Okay.
What job are you after?
Psychology.
Clinical?
Yes.
Clinical psychologist.
Why do you want to do that again?
You don't,
I'm going to question you
till you run out of answers.
You will run out of answers.
So if this is the time,
that's fine.
Why do you want to do,
what do you want to do?
Clinical psychology to help people.
Okay.
Why is that more important
to you than making money?
Because it helps me interact.
How
it sort of makes me happy to
see other people get over there,
bro.
Okay.
All right,
good.
Good.
Well that's pretty good.
You had lots of answers so sometimes
you can run people out of answers with
about three questions,
so,
all right,
so
small action perception nested in larger
action perception nested in larger
action perception all the way out too.
Well,
until you run out of answers.
Fundamentally,
right?
So,
and that's where at the edge
where you run out of answers,
that's where metaphysics takes over
because there's not an irrational domain
anymore.
You're in a metaphysical
domain at that point.
And so you have implicit assumptions
that you don't even know about that are
working on,
on,
on the fringes.
And we'll talk about that a little bit.
Okay?
So,
so then
we could take a category like,
hmm,
we'll do a micro analysis the same way.
So you're at home and
you're a tickling the baby.
All right?
So we'll note first.
That's not an abstraction,
right?
There's an actual baby and
you're moving your fingers.
And so that's not just an
abstract conceptualization.
It's,
it's also where your consciousness ends.
You're tickling the baby,
but you don't know how you're doing it.
You don't know the musculature,
you don't know how to manipulate
the little organs and everything.
You can just do it.
So Bang,
you're out of the perceptual
domain at that point.
It grounds out in voluntary action.
All right,
so you're tickling the baby.
What are you doing when you're tickling
the baby while you're making the baby
laugh?
Okay,
that's one way you're
playing with the baby.
Okay?
So fine.
That's a subset of the activity play with
baby and you can play peekaboo with a
baby or you can take tickle the baby,
you can clean the baby.
Those and all of that
could be part of playing.
And you might say,
well,
what are you doing when
you're playing with a baby?
And you'd say,
well,
I'm taking care of my family and fine.
And then you think,
well what?
What are you doing when you're
taking care of your family?
And you might say,
well,
I'm being a good parent.
And then you might say,
well,
what am I doing when
I'm being a good parent?
You might say,
well,
I'm being a good person.
And then you could say,
well,
why should you be a good person?
But we won't go any farther than that.
It's sort of,
because you can see
that that's sort of the,
in some sense,
that's an ultimate level of abstraction.
Okay,
so you could,
what do you do?
Someone comes up to you and you
tickling the baby and you say,
well,
I'm being a good person.
What they,
what are you doing?
I'm being a good person.
It's like it's a bit disjointed.
It isn't what the person
would expect as an answer.
They'd expect something more local.
But it's still true.
And so what's interesting is that
when you're doing something that's
what,
well,
I would say worthwhile.
That's probably the right
way of thinking about it.
You're doing a whole bunch of things
simultaneously and you're not really aware
of all those things,
but you are in some sense,
you know,
because if the purse,
someone might come along and say,
well what kind of idiot
tickles a baby like that?
It's like,
well what have they said?
Well they've kind of nailed you
here down on the micro tickle level,
but they're sort of also,
yeah,
taking a pretty good crack at this
high level system as well now.
And that's a problem.
So let's say,
well good parent is a subset
of being a good person,
but there's all sorts of other baby.
You have to be a good partner.
Maybe you have to be a good daughter.
Maybe you have to be a good,
nice,
you know,
your,
your ability to function as a good person
is composed of a very large number of
hierarchically nested subsystems.
And so when the person goes,
only an idiot would
take the baby like that.
And they go after that.
You might think,
well,
how upset you should,
should you get an answer is,
well,
how valid do you think their complaint is?
So let's say maybe it only an idiot
would tickle a baby like that and you
happened to be that idiot.
And so,
well,
maybe you're not a good person.
And so what does that mean?
It means that the map that consists
of all these nested subsystems has now
become unreliable.
And so how upset are you
going to get about that?
Well,
you know,
maybe you had a bad day at work and you're
kind of hypoglycemic and you had too
much to drink the night before.
And so someone says,
you know,
that's not how you tickle a baby.
You idiot and you cry.
Well why?
Well,
it's a pretty high level blow.
And so it's the sort of thing
you want to do if you want to do,
if you want to hurt someone,
it's not a good way to teach
someone because you teach
them down at the smallest
possible level.
The micro,
no,
you don't tickle a baby like that.
He'd tickle the baby like this and you're
doing a good job on everything else.
But if you're going to take a baby,
this is how you go about it.
And the person thinks,
well,
you know,
I'm doing a fairly good job,
but I've got this little thing I have
to work on and maybe I can manage it.
And so that works and how that works.
And you can have some sympathy for the
person at the same time because you might
say,
well,
I used to take a baby.
He's like an idiot too.
But you know it's,
it's fixable and most of use.
Okay.
And that's a nice thing to do
when you're arguing with someone.
You say,
look,
here's a bunch of things you're doing
right that are related to this that are
important.
Here's a small thing that maybe you
could alter slightly and it would make me
happy and maybe I'll return the
favor at some point and they think,
oh well maybe,
maybe I'll do that maybe.
And then they practice doing it.
You can give them a pat on the head
and then you're both happy about that.
That really works with people.
It really works.
So
okay,
so
what you see is that these
high level abstractions,
let's call them ethical abstractions,
are related to actions.
They're related.
And so you can see that relationship
from the good person to doing something
like tickle the baby
properly and then you can,
you can conceptualize it this way,
that you have this
massive overarching map,
which is something like
the story of your life,
including its extension future.
And then it consists of these subordinate
maps which can be broken down all the
way down to the level of actions.
And so then that explains
to you to some degree,
how you can do the impossible
job of calibrating your
emotional response because
roughly speaking,
your emotional response should be
proportionate to the level that's being
assaulted by the anomaly.